there's a trans woman sitting in the
audience
this is true story it was like a few
weeks ago i did six shows that weekend
this trans woman came to four of them
calls herself daphne
man this chick daphne was in there
cracking the [ __ ]
up at everything i said about
everybody it was amazing she was
laughing and it was fun to watch her
laugh
you could tell she was letting go with
something that was heavy and she threw
her head back and she smiled with all
her teeth she was having a great time
and the more fun she had i felt bad
because i knew
i had some trans jokes on low
and i thought to myself maybe i
shouldn't say these jokes because i
don't want to like [ __ ] her evening up
she's having so much fun
but then i thought to myself well if i
can't say it in front of us should i say
this [ __ ] at all so i let it rip
to my surprise daphne laughed harder
than trans jokes
than anybody in the room in fact
everybody in the room would look at her
to make sure it was okay
and i got off stages in the dressing
room i was like well it's a [ __ ]
weird show i'm
i'm sitting in a dress room by myself
just trying to figure out like
what the [ __ ] just happened out there
like why is it that this one woman can't
take any of these jokes
and daphne can take all of these jokes
so weird and then i realized ah
daphne used to be a man
so now i go out of the dressing room and
and like you can see like all the the
staff is there like cleaning the club up
the audience had gone and sitting at the
bar by herself
was daphne and she's like hey dave
come join me for a drink and i don't
want to think that i'm transphobic or
nothing something like [ __ ] i
i guess i could have at least drink and
we get some tequila and we're sitting
there
and and she was [ __ ] cool turns out
the daphne she wants to be a comedian
she was asking me for advice i told her
advice and all that [ __ ] and then she
says to me she says boy you sure do get
a bad rap
for your trans jokes i said daphne thank
you but you don't have to say that
i hope i didn't offend you she goes no
no
no no she said in fact i read about you
in the new york times i said you did
she said yeah she said i thought it was
interesting that they blamed you
for r kelly they said you normalized
them for telling jokes about it
i go yeah yeah they said that she goes i
wonder why they never said
that she normalized transgenders by
telling jokes about us
and i never thought about that it never
occurred to me
and we started making out and then like
i i reached up just to see what it felt
like i was like
oh what is what and it felt like [ __ ]
did that was just like
now i was hanging out with a friend of
mine he's a white guy you know we were
just hanging out
and we were lost in the city you know
he's smoking a joint now i don't know if
it's a coincidence that we were
lost and high and [ __ ] but
my wife buddy he was smoking a joint
dave dave it's the goddamn cops
i'm gonna ask him for directions
i said chip no chip don't do it
it was too late he was walking over
there this man was high as [ __ ]
excuse me excuse me sir
touching him and [ __ ] excuse me
you need some information uh it's not
confessing things you shouldn't confess
i'm a little high
all i want to know which way is third
street the cow was like hey
take it easy
you're on third street
you better be careful go ahead move it
move it
that's all that happened that's the end
of the story
now i know that's not amazing of some of
you
but yes one of these black fellas that
[ __ ] is [ __ ] incredible isn't it
i'm saying a black man would never dream
of talking to the police high
that's a waste of weed
serious
i mean i'll be scared to talk to the
police when i'm sleepy
they [ __ ] around get the wrong ideas you
know
oh my god that [ __ ] was on pcp
johnson i had to use necessary force
you saw them no no no paperwork just
just sprinkle some crack on them let's
get out of here
that's how it is but at the time i
didn't think was anything racial about
it i was just like man chip
you got [ __ ] lucky better be careful
but then another time me and chip are
driving
now i'm not driving chip is driving and
he's driving a little crazy he's been
drinking
i don't like to let my friends drive
drunk but you know
i was smoking a joint i couldn't really
say [ __ ] to the guy
and we get it a red light we stop at a
red light and a car pulls up next to us
and i'll never forget it chip he looks
at me he's all drunk and she's like
dave
i'm gonna race him
i knew it was a bad idea but i was high
i tried to explain them it was a bad
idea but all that came
out well [ __ ] sometimes you got race
huh
man that light turned green and chip
took off zig zagging and ships and no
one could pass another car didn't know
he was racing
then the police seen us and pulled us
over they understand i'm scared of [ __ ]
i mean come on the car smells like weed
i mean speeding this man is
[ __ ] drunk was scared
chip was not scared at all it was weird
he didn't turn his radio down and it was
weird a little bit
i mean if you get pulled over once you
turn your radio down nobody won't get
their ass beat to a soundtrack and [ __ ]
i'm saying chip had the music blasting
we're not gonna take it
just relax close your butt cheeks just
relax
let me do the talking
you wanna know what he said that's
almost exactly what he said
i couldn't believe it he says oh oh
sorry officer i
i didn't know i couldn't do that
i was [ __ ] shocked the cop said well
now you know
just get out of here just get the [ __ ]
out of here
[Applause]
she said okay oh i will sir thank you
what what's wrong with you dave
i didn't know i couldn't do that he said
that was good wasn't it
because i did know i couldn't do that
really you know who i'm gonna vote for
next time if things keep going the way
it's going is that gay dude
no mike pence
now this is the same club the punchline
this is 15 years ago
and i had just gotten back from from my
infamous uh
south africa trip and i came to the
punch line just to cheer myself up
it's a safe place where i could tell
some jokes
and i find out that this comedian i know
chris tucker who's in all those rush
hour movies
i find out that chris is in san
francisco too at
some charity event so i call him like yo
i just saw you at some charity event
i said i'm doing a show at the punch
line why don't you come by the club
after your event is that cool dave i
thought she was dead [ __ ] i'll come by
he said
he says is it okay if i bring some
friends because you know i'm with a lot
of people
like man you chris tucker you can bring
whatever the [ __ ] you want
and then i show up to the club late that
night
i walk into the dressing room and
sitting in the dressing room
is uh gavin newsom who at the time was
the mayor of san francisco
but now he's the governor of california
and sitting next to him was kamala
harris who at the time was
the d.a of san francisco now she's a
senator from california that's front
running
on the democratic ticket
and sit next to her was al gore
it's [ __ ] weird
sitting next to al gore was the guys
from google sergey and i don't know how
to say these
all right and it was chris tucker
and and ben jealous who at the time was
the president of the naacp
who was all just at this big charity
dinner and and
and paul mooney was drinking scotch
and we all was just in there and you
know first i was a little uncomfortable
we started talking and
we all got along really well
at some point uh kama harris says
she says to me she goes you know a
friend of mine is announcing
his candidacy for president tomorrow i
went to college with him
i'm like what i go barack obama she goes
you've heard of him
like yo i just read about this dude and
she goes yo yeah
we talking she goes you know what she
says let's
let's call him on the phone i said what
the [ __ ]
and she picks the phone up and she downs
and she's listening like this
and she goes ah this is voicemail
and she gives me phone she goes leave me
a message
you know i didn't know what to say i
just said what you say to any black dude
is
running for president you know stay low
running his exact pattern this kind of
[ __ ]
[Applause]
and then the last thing i say is you
know what i said
sir well i really do believe you can do
this like man i'm wishing you luck
now next day i wake up and go for coffee
at a place called the embarcadero it's
like an eatery by the sea in san
francisco
and i'm walking to the coffee shop and
there's a police line and i can't cross
the tape but then i figure [ __ ] i'm
dave chappelle so i go into the thing
like this
and the police yoke me these
[ __ ] like tackle me immediately
and i see over the police shoulder
gavin newsom i couldn't remember his
name but i remember last the night
before i had kept
teasing him and said he looked like
christian bale the guy from the batman
movies
uh so i see him and i can't remember
anything so i'm just like
batman help
[Applause]
and he stops just like dave and
and then the police see that the mayor
knows me so they're all like
oh sorry about that goodbye and he's
like hey back up everybody and he just
picks me up he's like i'm really sorry
about that i'm like i'm fine don't worry
about it
and he's like he's like listen i'm here
with the prince would you like to meet
him i'm like i know prince that's my
[ __ ]
and we go around the corner and it was
prince charles the prince of england
i didn't know the protocol of meeting
royalty and not supposed to touch him
i dapped him up like a [ __ ] mine [ __ ]
just hugging them and [ __ ] like this
dapping them up
and that [ __ ] was cool too that's
really [ __ ] weird
and then i was just out there in the
upside down not having no tv show trying
to figure life out
and the election was going on in the
background and this guy barack obama
was picking up steam this [ __ ]
was killing it
and i had a chance to go to the last
debate on the democratic ticket
and i went it's me and chris tucker
sitting in myrtle beach south carolina
it's the last three candidates it was
barack obama john edwards and hillary
clinton
now obama is a lot taller than edwards
and clinton and he had the center podium
and at one point they're all on stage
and they start fussing and obama goes
look
none of us are perfect like this his
hands was like this and there was light
shining behind his head and the other
two candidates was looking up and they
and i was sitting in the audience like
this [ __ ] looks like jesus
[Applause]
and i realized in that moment
that i was looking at the next president
of the united states i was certain of it
i couldn't explain it
but i knew what i was seeing and i got
really excited
and i'm not that kind of guy i said i
gotta meet this [ __ ]
so i i stayed they were all on stage
doing interviews
and i just waited i was waiting and
waiting and then
john edwards was done with his
interviews first because everybody knew
he wasn't going to win
and i see john edwards and i said hey
hey senator edwards i just want to say
hi and that [ __ ] look at me like
hmm
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you gonna lose anyway and
then he left and then hillary clinton
just walked by me and won the steve
harvey suits
[Applause]
but obama was taking forever
everybody wanted to talk to him when i
knew the media saw exactly what i
saw there was no question about it dad
was the guy i waited and i waited
and finally must have been over an hour
and a half he finishes his last
interview he was like
thank you very much good to talk to you
and he turns around
and he's we make eye contact he sees me
and when he sees me he looks up he goes
dave chappelle
and and obama did me the same way i did
prince
charles he
like bro hugged me and he pulled me in
and i'll never forget this he said in my
ear
i got your message thank you very much
new york
good night
[Applause]
you got to make life interesting like
that because the [ __ ] is flimsy
life is flimsy you think you're going to
live but not going to live forever
it's dangerous out here we know what's
going on i travel now you know i usually
think dc had the roughest ghettos in the
country
no [ __ ]
i have seen some [ __ ] now
oh there's some rough rough areas
outside of dc
yeah everybody should go to the ghetto i
was taking it together one time that's
the worst when you get taken you're not
expecting to go
you know usually you want to know when
you're going to get it like i'm going to
see some wild [ __ ] i got to prepare
myself i'm going to do something crazy
when you're taking it's different i had
a limousine driver
it was after a show it was late at night
it's like three in the morning
had a limousine drive he's a nice guy
talking to me and [ __ ] oh hey where you
from though
dc word
that's a rough city man and the cell
phone started ringing hold on one second
hello oh what's up [ __ ] what what the
[ __ ] stole that what what the [ __ ]
no no no
[ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] it i'm on my way
hey
i gotta make a stop real quick
at three o'clock in the morning i didn't
know he was taking me to the ghetto at
first
i started looking out the window i was
like what the [ __ ] gun store gun store
look at store gun store where the [ __ ]
you taking me
this don't look good he didn't say [ __ ]
just pulled up in front of an old
rickety building that looked like a
project
now i've never been there before i'm not
sure if it was a project but
it certainly had all the familial
symptoms of a project
a [ __ ] crackhead ran this way
and then another one jumped out of tree
and [ __ ]
[Applause]
i said i'll be right back and left me
took the keys with me just let me three
o'clock in the morning
in front of a project in a [ __ ]
limousine
this was not good i was like man i gotta
look around see if i can see some
landmarks and
figure out where i'm at might have to
escape on foot
now this is when i know i was in a bad
neighborhood you only see this in the
worst
neighborhoods remember it's three
o'clock in the morning it's three
o'clock in the morning
i look out the window it was a [ __ ]
baby
standing on the corner
and the baby the baby didn't even look
scared he was just standing there
i mean it made me sad it made me say it
really good because i wanted to help the
baby
i don't trust you either i'm sorry click
click
the old baby on the corner trick eh
you're not gonna fall for that [ __ ]
where's this limousine driver you know i
stopped feeling bad
as time goes by i start feeling worse
like man what is wrong with me what the
hell is wrong i am scared of a baby
and this baby could be in trouble he
might need my help i got to do something
but i wasn't going to get out the car
i'm serious man i just cracked the
window a little bit
there's a whole limousine i can roll it
down
[Applause]
hey baby baby go home man it's three
o'clock in the morning what the [ __ ] are
you doing now
[Applause]
the baby said i'm selling weed [ __ ]
i wasn't expecting that
i'm sorry i had to buy two bags from the
coma they're gonna get two when i get
too funny
[Applause]
got back in the car and rolled me a
joint man that [ __ ] was scary man
every once in a while like a crack kid
would come up to the car and look in the
window it was like jurassic park and
should he be looking on the con
hey get out of here cracky
that baby was still standing there man
that's not feeling bad again yeah we
make you feel guilty sometimes
man what is wrong with me man i have
just bought weed from from an infant
i can't condone this kind of behavior
what am i thinking i can't let the fear
ruin my morals
got to do something
hey baby stop selling wheat all right
you got your whole life ahead of you
he said [ __ ] you [ __ ] i got kids to
feed
and this is that very moment when the
crackheads run across the street and got
hit by a car
i know it was a hit and run the police
did it
that's all right they springed some
crack on him he got back up
[Music]
you